you left without me
you were late again well I had to put on
my undercover minivan disguise
say hello to Harvey Norgan Blume CPA
recently divorced father of two with a
dark sexual secret what's your cover
angry captive okay so you do not like my
ensemble I'm just concerned that you may
find it hard to pursue a criminal on
foot while wearing man sandals but the
sandals define Harvey
he's a sandals guy captain why the
babysitting why are you micromanaging me
you think I want to be sitting here with
you instead of running my precinct yes
it was a rhetorical question I've spent
the last 12 years fighting for my first
command and I'm not gonna let you screw
it up because you refuse to take your
job seriously hey I do take my job
seriously I put away bad guys that's
what matters well so does doing your
paperwork showing up on time wearing
proper footwear that's not Harvey well
so here's the deal you're gonna have a
superior officer babysitting you on
every one of your cases and when you
show me that you can do your job every
part of your job perfectly
okay counteroffer I give you fifty bucks
and you let me do whatever I want
fine we'll do it your way from this
point on I'll do every part of the job
perfectly perfect her than perfectly
it's more perfectly
he said that imperfectly I was testing
you you did perfectly quick update on
the tagger situation he is currently
spray-painting our van right now
you're busted already go we got up oh
hey captain hi
so I was able to procure that $50 after
all and my offer still stands
let me do whatever I want and the $40
that's how much I actually have is yours
no fair enough I only have 30 anyway
well I guess in order to get you to stop
micromanaging me I'm enough to get back
the most important piece of police work
there is writing a perfect report good
I'm anxious to read it and I'm anxious
to restore my status as a lone wolf
anything else detective yeah I'm gonna
do one more lone wolf diggin me hey
Sarge do you know where we keep the
glitter I just want to make sure this
report for the captain is extra sparkly
what are you doing for Alton look if I
have to do things his way I'm gonna do
them my way okay it was nice working
with you I'm not scared of him okay I'm
not scared of anyone
oh also the tagger do repeat us on your
minivan I'm sorry please don't chase
after me
you